Imagine stepping into a world
right the mists.
They just never lift.
There's this ancient evil
running the show, and every
single choice you make could be
the difference between, well,
life and something arguably much
worse.
Yeah, undeath and Borovia isn't
exactly peaceful retirement.
Exactly.
That's the world we're talking
about.
Borovia's pure gothic horror,
constant dread.
Hope is well.
Hope is thin on the ground
there.
Very thin.
And we're zooming in today on
one particular town, Valaki,
which has just gone through
something pretty intense.
It really has.
It's like a microcosm of the
whole realms.
Despair, isn't it?
You're about to see just how
fast the town can fall, how its
freedoms just evaporate, and how
people get, well, broken.
So today we're doing a deep dive
into a really specific, really
rich set of sources.
We've got detailed accounts from
session 13.
This is from a group of
adventurers trying to navigate
this bleak landscape.
And these aren't just scribbled
notes.
We have their full session
reports, like the raw visceral
details and even verbatim logs
from their game master.
It gives us this unfiltered look
right into the story as it's
happening.
Yeah, it's like a window, isn't
it?
Full of desperate choices,
chilling stuff, encounters with
some truly nasty creatures.
So our mission for this deep
dive is basically to pull out
the biggest moments, the most
unsettling details, and what it
all means.
Right.
We want you to get a quick but,
you know, thorough understanding
of the dark forces moving the
pieces, how these heroes are
pushing back, and the grip that
Strad von Zarevich has on
everything.
It just keeps tightening it,
really.
Does It's about more than just
the play by play, It's about the
implications.
What does it all signify for
this cursed place and everyone
stuck there?
OK, so let's start where things
often start in Borovia, with
Strad making a move, an
unwelcome invitation.
Yeah, and what's fascinating
here is how he does it.
Strad.
He's the apex predator, right?
He doesn't need to roar a
whisper, a polite note.
That's enough to show he's in
charge.
He sets the stage, lays out the
terms, and just lets the
psychological pressure cook.
That's a great way to put it.
So our adventurers, they're kind
of holed up in the Blue Water
Inn in Valaki.
They think of it as their
borrowed sanctuary.
A borrowed sanctuary.
I like the description, it
sounds safe, but it's really
just a cage with slightly nicer
furniture offering this illusion
of security.
Right.
And then BAM, a messenger shows
up.
The sources say this guy has a
face pale as the mists like a
ghost delivering bad news.
Or, worse than bad news,
something insidious.
And it's a letter sealed with
Strad's own sigil, no mistaking
who it's from.
And the letter itself, Oh, it's
a piece of work.
The notes call it honeyed words,
but you can feel this chill of
civility coming off.
It like cold metal wrapped in
velvet.
It's polite, Technically a
summons, but it's coming from
the devil himself.
That's not just dinner, is it?
It's a test.
Absolutely, and the source is
quoted directly.
It's worth hearing, my friends,
know that it is I who have
brought you to this land, my
home, and know that I alone can
release you from it.
Oof.
Straight out of the gate, I own
you.
Pretty much, it continues.
I bid you dine at my castle so
that we can meet and civilize
surroundings.
Your passage here will be a safe
one.
I await your arrival and it's
signed your host, Srod von
Zarevich.
Your host.
The sheer arrogance.
It's calculated, isn't it?
This isn't just him showing off
his power, it's it's that
psychological mastery you
mentioned.
Yeah, he's not demanding.
He's inviting them into a trap.
He's asserting control through
this terrifying politeness.
Basically screaming you have
your choice.
Exactly.
He makes it crystal clear.
I brought you here, only I can
let you go.
So right away, he's positioned
himself as both their jailer and
their only, like, potential
Liberator.
That's a horrible paradox, isn't
it?
Designed to just break their
spirits before they even get to
the castle.
It tells you right away this
isn't just going to be about
swords and spells.
It's a battle for their minds,
their wills, maybe their souls,
orchestrated by someone who
genuinely seems to enjoy the
torment.
So this invitation lands a test,
as you said.
How do they handle it?
Stuck in their sanctuary,
getting a dinner invite from the
devil?
Do they just crumble?
Well, that's the surprising
part.
Their response was defiant.
A collective?
Not yet.
I like that it's not a never,
but it's a not on your terms,
but OK, let's dig into that.
The session notes must have more
in the debate, right?
How did each of them react
individually?
Oh yeah, the notes are great
here.
They capture the internal
struggle.
So you have Traxidor, he's the
half off cleric life domain.
His whole thing is life healing
and he immediately flashes back
to Yester Hill, remembering
Straud's presence there.
Yester Hill, Yeah, that was bad,
wasn't it, with the tree
monster?
Horrific, and Traxidor describes
Struds involvement not as a
fight, but as cold amusement.
Like Strud was just toying with
them like cats with mice.
So for Traxidor, facing this
power that could just snuff out
life, it was a deep threat to
his whole purpose, his faith,
His caution was real, born from
seeing Straud's power first.
Hand makes sense.
Who else?
And there's Radley Fulthorne,
human fighter but an Eldritch
Knight, so he's got that mix of
muscle and magic.
Right, the pragmatic 1.
Yeah, and true to form, he
throws in some dark humor,
starts joking about the wine
selection at Castle Ravenlock.
You know, facing down this
absolute dread with sarcasm.
It's a coping mechanism, I
guess.
Yeah, maybe just grim
acceptance.
Could be either, it's how he
deals.
Then you've got Diamond Cobain,
the half elf rogue swashbuckler.
The notes say.
He was unreadable as ever, just
stood near the window, quietly
flicking a silver coin.
Ah, the rogue.
Always watching, assessing his
silence probably speaks volumes.
Calculating the odds maybe?
Exactly, he's not showing his
hand.
But then there's Sir and
Ironwood.
He's the awesome art paladin.
Oath of Vengeance.
Radiant Vengeance is literally
in his description.
OK, so I'm guessing he wasn't
keen on dinner.
Keen is not the word.
He basically scoffed at the
idea.
Pure righteous indignation.
Said something like if the Count
wants to eat with them, he
should descend from his rotting
throne and come to them.
Wow.
OK, so fiery defiance there.
That's his oath talking.
No intimidation, no playing by
Stroud's rules.
He's the direct confrontation
guy.
But despite these, you know,
different personal takes, the
caution, the sarcasm, the
silence, the fury.
So they all landed on the same
page.
Not yet, not yet.
They refused.
The notes mention the taste of
winter splinters Bark, that
giant, horrible tree creature
from Yester Hill was still on
their blades.
That fight was fresh.
A victory, but a brutal 1.
So this refusal, it's not just
saying no to dinner, it's a
statement.
We're not your pawn.
Exactly.
And probably, almost definitely.
It ramps up Strawd's interest in
them.
They're not just new toys
anymore, They're toys that talk
back.
Which leads to the chilling
question.
What happens when you poke the
bear?
Especially when the bear owns
the forest, The Cave, and, well,
your soul?
The consequences?
They come fast and they're
brutal.
Valaki, they're supposed safe
haven.
It starts at slide Into Darkness
almost immediately.
Right the morning after the
invitation, the sources describe
the dawn as dull and thin as a
blade.
No real sun, just that perpetual
Barovian gloom grayed on.
Filtering through mist.
Sets the mood perfectly.
Doesn't.
It it does, and then they hear
it.
The sound of hammers outside the
Blue Water Inn, hammers nailing
on wood, echoed like a funeral
drum.
OK, that's ominous.
What were they nailing up?
Proclamations and worse.
They were being read aloud by
townsfolk described as cowed and
bloodied, still reeling from the
massacre at the Festival of the
Blazing Sun.
The festival that was another
disaster.
So the town's already
traumatized vulnerable.
Precisely.
And who's issuing these
proclamations?
Lady Fiona walked her.
Remember her?
The conspirator lurking in the
background.
Yeah, playing a long game.
Well, game over.
She's now openly assumed the
office of Burgamaster and get
this, an open fealty to Count
Strad.
Oh wow, so no more pretense?
It's not just a power shift,
it's Valaki openly bending the
knee to Strad.
And she claims she took office
by the will of the people who
threw off the yoke of the inept
Baron Vargas Vlakovic.
It's such a twisted narrative,
blaming the victims of Strad's
terror for their own quote UN
quote liberation into something
even worse.
A darker servitude.
So what were these edicts?
How bad did it get?
How quickly?
It's a chilling list, a spiral
into tyranny First, and this one
hits hard.
The further worship of the
Morning Lord is declared
heretical and is prohibited.
No.
Wow, the morning Lord is like
the only symbol of light they
have left, isn't it?
Pretty much.
The sources call it the last
fragile bulwark against the
darkness.
So this decree, it just crushes
spiritual hope, isolates people
completely in their despair.
It's a blow right to the soul of
the town.
OK, that's bad.
What else?
She immediately militarizes
things.
Her loyal retainer, Ernst
Larnac.
He's now the reef, commanding
all the surviving town militia.
So the town guard now works for
her and by extension Strawd?
Yep.
Not protection.
It's control, turning defenders
into oppressors.
And then there's the secret
police.
Establishes an anonymous order
of protectors, basically Valaki
civic wardens and spiritual
inquisitors demanding
unquestioning obedience.
Instant paranoia.
Neighbors suspecting neighbors.
Total breakdown of trust.
So you can't worship freely, the
guards are against you and there
are skies everywhere.
Sounds lovely.
And it gets grimmer.
Dignity stripped away, the
bodies of all slain townsfolk
are to be brought to a mass
grave north of town, piled up
like so much refuse.
Dehumanizing.
No proper mourning, just
disposal.
Shows utter contempt for life.
Absolutely.
Then restrictions.
All persons must obtain
permission from the Reeve before
leaving Valaki.
Trapped, Valaki's now a prison.
A prison with a curfew, everyone
inside before dark.
The night belongs to Strad's
regime now.
OK, this is a complete lockdown.
Is there anything else?
Because this is already
terrifying.
One more and it's perhaps the
most sinister the Society of
Valaki's maidens.
That sounds deceptively quaint.
Deceptively is the word.
Every eligible young woman is
forcibly inducted under watchers
watchful matronly eye.
The notes call it a mockery of
protection, more like cattle
counted before slaughter.
Oh.
God for Strad, is that the
implication?
It heavily hints at a sinister
purpose.
Maybe for Strad.
Yeah.
The edict says all marriageable
young women will attend the
society's inaugural meeting to
affirm their suitability.
Suitability for what?
It hangs there.
Really ominous.
A fate worse than servitude
seems likely.
This is chilling, a complete
takeover, spiritual, physical,
social, even down to controlling
young women's lives for some
dark purpose.
And just a hammer.
At home, Radley sees a wanted
poster for Victor, the old Baron
son.
He rips it down.
Victor's a fugitive now.
Isaac Strozny, the baron's
monstrous enforcer, also
haunted.
The old regime is being actively
erased.
Only Watchers and Straud's dark
future is allowed.
So the party witnesses all this.
How do they react?
What do they see walking through
this newly oppressed town?
They walk through what the notes
call Valaki's burned veins,
scorched houses where Straud's
minions literally drove families
out into the streets.
Deliberate terror tactics
confirmed by townsfolk.
Yep, townsfolk confirms some
fires were set just to flush
people out.
The charred wood, the smell of
smoke, constant reminders of the
violence and the cost of
defiance.
And the mass grave, do they see
that?
They did.
At the North End of town, a
great pyre burned, a pillar of
greasy black smoke, consuming
bodies into cinder and whispers.
The imagery.
It's stark children staring into
the flames, fathers pushing
carts with wrapped bodies,
widespread devastation,
unceremoniousied death.
Life is cheap.
Death is meaningless under this
new rule.
It makes you think, doesn't it?
How fast an entire town, social
fabric, its freedoms can just
unravel, How quickly tyranny
takes root?
What would you do in that kind
of suffocating environment?
It's terrifying to consider.
Absolutely terrifying.
And amidst all this grim
reality, this desolation, the
adventurers are looking for
answers, trying to understand
what's happening.
And they stumble into, well,
Blinsky's toys.
Blinsky's Toys Right, described
as an unlikely Crucible of
secrets and mockery, sounds
about right for Borovia.
It really is.
It's this place where childhood
innocence gets twisted into
something.
And they meet the man himself
get off Blinski.
They do.
The Wizard of Tiny Wonders
greets them with manic Glee,
wearing a jester's cap.
He's got a monkey named Piccolo
on his shoulder and his tagline.
Is no fun, Is no Blinski.
Yeah, yeah, I remember that.
It perfectly captures that
forced, slightly insane
cheerfulness you find in
Borovia, like finding joy in the
morbid because there's nothing
else.
Exactly.
He's a living example of the
Barovian psyche under pressure.
So they're looking around his
shop shelves full of sad eyed
marionettes and morbid dioramas,
and then Soren sees something.
What is it?
Something that makes his
celestial blood run cold.
It's a doll, the spitting image
of Irena Kuleana.
Oh wow, OK, for Soren the
paladin trying to protect her,
that must have been a shock
seeing her likeness as this
lifeless toy.
A really chilling moment, like a
premonition, maybe.
I hint that Stroud's obsession,
his reach, gets everywhere, even
into a toy shop.
So what does Blinsky say?
How does he explain having Irena
dolls?
He kind of half giggles, half
sobs, which says a lot about his
mental state and reveals they
were commissions from Isaac
Strozny.
Isaac the Baron's former
enforcer, the one with the
monster arm.
That's the one, apparently.
Isaac kept coming back,
demanding more dolls, but each
one was never quite right.
This was Isaac's price for
letting Blinsky live, a
grotesque payment for a
grotesque obsession.
So it wasn't Stride
commissioning them, it was
Isaac, but still focused on
Irina.
Right, which is disturbing in
its own way.
Radley, being Radley, actually
buys the doll, trades coin for
it.
Prioritizing Intel over comfort,
you know?
Yeah, that sounds like him
getting grimly practical.
And Blinsky says he made dozens
of them for Isaac.
Always imperfect.
It just highlights this deep,
disturbing fixation Isaac had,
which is horrifyingly similar to
Strad's own obsession with
Irena.
It's like this malevolent theme
echoing through the town.
A shared madness, almost.
What else did they notice in the
shop?
They saw a puppet that looked
like Strad of.
Course he has a strad puppet.
Right.
And when they asked, Blinsky
just casually says he makes toys
for every child's proclivities.
Like, Oh yeah, some kids like
vampires.
What's the big deal?
It shows how normalized Strad's
evil presence is, even in kids
toys.
That's deeply unsettling.
Did Blinsky offer or anything
else any useful info amidst the
creepy toys?
Actually, yes.
He starts babbling about Lydia
Petrovna, the Baroness who was
hanged.
Turns out he knew her as a child
and she was the sister of Father
Lucian Petrovich, the priest at
Saint Andrews Church.
Okay, a connection there, Does
it lead anywhere?
It might, Bolinsky says.
Their family line goes way back
to Tasha Petrovna, a priestess
of the Morning Lord before Strad
even became a vampire.
Whoa, OK, that's interesting.
Pre Strad history.
And here's the kicker.
Rumor has it Tasha Petrovna's
tomb is in Castle Raven loft
itself.
Seriously.
In the belly of the beast?
Yep.
So this little tidbit dropped by
1/2 Mad Toy Maker.
It's this potential sliver of
hope, A connection to ancient
history, maybe forgotten
knowledge.
Something that could help them
fight Strad.
Or it could be just it's another
lure, another trap.
Come into my castle,
adventurers.
Exactly.
Or just another grave waiting to
swallow them whole.
Hope and Barovia always comes
with teeth, doesn't it?
Seems like it.
How did the encounter end?
Blinsky just waves them out.
His usual creepy squeal is no
fun is no Brinsky.
Leaving them with dolls,
secrets, and a lot more
questions.
That shop really is a microcosm
of Borovia, isn't it?
Innocence, twisted obsession
made manifest.
Hope tangled up with death.
Perfectly put.
And the Irena dolls, especially
that thread connecting Isaac and
Strawd.
It just paints this grim picture
of pervasive malevolent
influence.
So after that dose of creepy,
where do they head next?
Still digging into Valaki's rot.
Yep, they head to the manner of
the dead Baron Vargas Volakovic,
and it's exactly what you'd
expect.
Looted, defiled, vandalized,
fine things already picked over
by scavengers.
Shows how fast order breaks
down.
How the mighty.
And clues left them.
It's wreckage.
Well, they find one locked
bedroom upstairs.
Everything else is trash but
this one room is locked tight.
Interesting, how do they get in?
Radley armored shoulder meets
locked door.
He just batters it open.
No time for finesse, I guess.
Getting things done.
What's inside?
It's described as mostly
Spartan, but there are empty
wine bottle scattered around and
more Irena dolls just like the
ones from Blinski's.
No way.
So Victor, the Baron's son, he
was obsessed too.
Scenes like it It's not just a
room.
The notes call it a shrine to
obsession and failure.
It echoes Isaac's fixation.
This repetition of the dolls is
really chilling, like a late
motif, underscoring this
pervasive darkness, this creepy
fixation linked to Strawd.
OK, that's deeply messed up.
Did they find anything else in
the manner?
Yeah, the attic.
Surprisingly, it looked like
looters had skipped it.
Maybe seemed too mundane, but
the notes say it was worse than
the chaos downstairs.
Worse how?
Family heirlooms, portraits just
rotting in the rafters, a
family's history decaying.
And there's this narrow path
through the junk leading to a
heavy wooden door marked with a
crude skull.
Subtle.
And a scratched warning.
All is not well.
OK, Yeah, that's usually a bad
sign, especially in Borovia.
Definitely.
It signals something more
personal, more dangerous.
Forbidden secrets maybe?
So who tries the door?
CERN again?
He seems like the type.
Good guess.
Soren steps up, tries the door,
and bam, Glyph of Warding.
Arcane lightning slams into his
chest.
Ouch.
Did it stop him?
Not Soren.
The notes say he just gritted
his teeth against the pain,
showed that paladin resolve and
tried again.
Successfully opens it on the
second go.
Tough guy.
OK, so what's behind door #2
what was Victor hiding?
Victor's Secret, a haphazard
Wizards workshop.
It's clearly amateur hour, not a
pro setup.
What kind of stuff was in there?
Weird experiments.
Pretty weird. 6 animated cat
skeletons prowling the rafters,
empty eye sockets gleaming.
Creepy.
Animated cat skeletons.
Normal hobbies.
And three small mannequins
turned facing the wall like
scolded children.
Just bizarre, macabre and
childish at the same time.
They also find this incomplete,
badly sewn wizard's robe in a
trunk.
So he was really trying to be a
wizard, maybe try to find a way
out.
That seems to be the
implication, especially given
the biggest discovery.
Under a scorched rug, they find
a teleportation circle.
A way out, fine.
Not so fast.
Radley, with his eldritch night
training, takes one look and
knows it's bad news.
The runes are jagged, broken.
He calls it a death sentence.
So not a way out, but a trap or
just incompetent magic.
Lethally incompetent it seems.
The notes say there are
footprints and soot and
scorching around it, indicating
someone else had already tried
to use it with catastrophic
results.
You mean like?
They exploded.
Or worse, the notes don't
explicitly say.
But yeah, the implication is a
terrible, messy end for anyone
desperate enough to try this
flawed circle.
A chilling reminder of how
dangerous untrained magic is
here.
So the implications?
Victor, the privileged son, was
into some seriously dark,
dangerous magic, desperate to
escape Barovia.
Seems very likely.
It shows the depth of despair
that pushes even the elite to
such reckless acts, and his
obsession with Irina mirroring
Isaacs, It paints this picture
of a town drowning in these dark
fixations may be seated by straw
about himself.
Victor's just this tragic
figure, driven to extremes by
the sheer hopelessness of it
all.
OK so Valaki is just layers upon
layers of grim.
With the immediate crisis of
Watchers rule established and
the disturbing secrets of the
Barons family uncovered, did
they shift focus back to the
other big mystery, The Bones of
Saint Andrew?
They did.
Those relics were still missing,
and they were crucial for, you
know, maybe restoring some
sanctity to the church or at
least protecting it.
So they head back to the
graveyard next to the ruined
Church of Saint Andrew.
And how do they plan to find
clues in a graveyard?
Talk to the residents.
Sort of.
Traxidor uses his divine magic.
Speak with dead.
Classic cleric move.
Who do they talk to?
They find the body of Myloy,
remember him, the grave rubber.
The notes describe him as barely
out of boyhood.
Just a kid, really.
Yeah.
Tragic.
What does Mylogious Spirit tell
him?
He confesses whispers via
tracidor that Henrik Vander
Fort, the coffin maker, paid him
to steal the bones.
Henrik, the coffin maker.
OK, a solid lead.
Why did Milo's do it?
To feed his starving siblings he
use the money for food.
It just underlines the
desperation in the lucky doesn't
it?
Kids robbing graves just to
survive makes you question who
the real villains are sometimes.
It really does.
Even sacrilege becomes an act of
survival.
So they have their lid.
Henrik, the coffin maker.
What happens when they pay him a
visit?
They arrive at the coffin shop
front doors, a jar already a bad
sign.
Never a good sign.
Downstairs is just filled with
coffins stacked like cord wood.
More big foreshadowing, Maybe
the air smells like sawdust, but
also something else, something
rank.
Uh oh.
Where do they find Henrik or
what's left of him?
Well, Dermont, being the sneaky
one, checks upstairs first,
finds a storeroom, lumber,
tools, and half a dozen crates.
Crates.
Anything weird about them?
Yeah, the crates have soil in
them, and they've been burst
open from within, dirt scattered
everywhere.
Burst open from within like
something hatched.
Exactly, that's the chilling
implications.
Something non human.
Use these crates like, well,
like coffins, but in reverse,
like a grotesque nursery.
OK, that's disturbing.
What about Henrik?
The smell leads the rest of the
party.
That rank decay smell leads them
to a back bedroom where, as the
notes put it, horror had
bloomed.
Oh boy, how bad.
Bad Henriks corpse is there,
crumpled, eviscerated.
His guts are described as being
scrawled across the walls and
ceiling like some kind of
horrible finger painting.
Jesus.
OK, that's graphic.
The air is thick with flies just
buzzing over the scene, and
there are bloody handprints and
footprints on the walls, even
the ceiling.
A.
Ceiling how?
That's the clue, isn't it?
Indicating his killers seem to
defy gravity, points straight to
something nonhuman, something
that can climb walls, stick to
ceiling.
Vampire spawn had to be the
things that hatch from the
crates.
Seems incredibly likely they
hatched, killed Henrik, and
presumably flew off.
Back to their master, maybe.
And the bones, were they there?
Nope.
Bones are gone, only thing left
is a bag of coins near the body.
Henrik's payment, presumably for
his betrayal, his life, his
soul.
So the spawn hatched, killed
their helper, took the bones and
vanished.
A deliberate, calculated horror
show.
Yeah, a very disturbing
birthplace for these creatures,
hidden inside a mundane coffin
shop.
It just shows the kind of hidden
evils operating beneath the
surface.
And then there's Radley's
reaction, isn't there?
The notes mentioned something
pretty stark.
Yeah, this is a moment.
Radley, apparently without much
hesitation, bent down, sawed the
head from Henrik's neck, and
tossed it over her shoulder like
a sack of potatoes.
Whoa.
OK, just took his head.
Why?
The notes describe it as having
no reverence for traitors, just
grim trophies.
It's his moment of stark, maybe
horrifying brutality.
Feels like a shift, doesn't it?
For Radley, maybe.
For the whole party, yeah.
Taking a head as a trophy?
That's not standard hero
behavior.
Not at all.
It shows how Borovia is maybe
coroting them, hardening them.
They're adapting, but the
adaptation itself is brutal,
cold pragmatism taking over.
And the notes say they left the
body and told no one.
Yep.
Left the corpse to Moulder.
Kept the head head, kept it
secret.
They're operating outside normal
morality now, embracing the grim
reality of the place, sharing
this dark secret, this burden.
It really makes you ask, what's
the psychological toll?
How much of their humanity are
they sacrificing just to
survive, let alone win?
When do the heroes start looking
like the monsters they fight?
That's the million gold piece
question in Barovia, isn't it?
So they get back to the Blue
Water Inn and now they have a
new problem.
Hiding a severed head, right?
Can't exactly leave that lying
around the tap room.
Exactly.
The notes are clear.
Danica Martikoff, the innkeeper.
She's tough, but fair.
She would have pitched them into
the street if she knew.
So even as they get harder,
darker, there are still lines
they can't cross openly.
Not if they want to keep their
allies.
So what's the vibe at the inn
now under washers?
It's unusually quiet.
People are obeying the curfew.
They're scared of the new civic
wardens and Inquisitors.
Watchers.
Fear tactics are working.
The oppression has settled in
quickly.
Did.
They learn anything else there.
Soren asks Danica about Victor,
the baron's son they just
investigated.
She doesn't know much, calls him
peculiar and reclusive,
demanding and narcissistic.
But her eyes, the notes say,
suggested she wished she knew
even less.
Yeah, Victor sounds like the
kind of creepy nobody wants to
know too much about.
Seems so.
Later, though, they get a small
moment of, well, I'm not exactly
relief, but maybe distraction.
Rick Tavio joins them for
supper.
Rick Tavio, the traveling Bard.
Or maybe, as the notes hint, a
Monster Hunter and Motley.
Yeah, there's more to him than
meets the eye.
Probably he shares some Brandy
from far off Durkon apparently,
and he tells stories of other
lands, places beyond the mists.
A glimpse of freedom.
For a second, yeah, they see the
glimmer of what freedom might
taste like before Barovia closed
its jaws again.
It's crucial that little moment
highlights the fear in Valaki.
The fleeting nature of any hope
reminds them what they're
fighting for, even if it feels
impossible.
Bittersweet taste of normal.
But that glimmer fades fast,
doesn't it?
The reality Brovia always
crashes back in.
Always morning comes dull and
thin as a blade, just like the
day the edicts were posted.
Time to leave a lackey.
They depart with the Mardikovs
wagon, Adrian and Dag.
There were Raven allies hauling
wine towards Kresk, heading
West.
OK, moving on.
But they still have the head,
right?
How are the Martikoffs feeling
about that?
Not great.
This is where that friction
really shows up.
Adrian and Dag keep casting
nervous glances at Radley's
Grizzly Prize.
They're clearly uncomfortable.
I mean, yeah, understandable.
And then Soren makes it worse.
He apparently just starts
flaying the skin from the skull
like he was butchering a deer
right there on the wagon.
Oh, come on, Soren, read.
The room.
Or the wagon, I guess.
Seriously, the Martikoffs just
balk.
They threatened to dump the wine
right there on the road and go
home, their trust in the parties
visibly cracking like old oak.
This is bad.
Their actions, their Grin
trophies are alienating their
allies.
It shows the cost, doesn't it?
How far can they push this
before they lose everyone and
maybe lose themselves?
It's a huge question hanging
over them.
And just as that tension is
peaking, they encounter trouble
on the road.
Of course they do.
It's the old Svalich Rd.
What happens?
3 Ragged strangers approach from
the east look like peasants
limping, begging for silver.
OK, classic encounter setup.
What's their story?
They claim their villages are
being tormented by war creatures
and they need silver to make
weapons or tools.
Were creatures interesting given
their allies are were Ravens?
How does the party respond?
They warn them off Falaki tell
them it's no sanctuary now
describe watchers new rules.
The fear basically don't go
there.
Seems reasonable.
How do the peasants take the
news?
Their gratitude curdles like
sour milk.
Their faces twist and then
transformation.
Oh no, they're the word
creatures.
Yep, right before the party's
eyes, bones cracking, fur
tearing through flesh, they turn
into werewolves, wolves with
human eyes and human hunger.
Ambush A brutal, horrifying
transformation scene right there
on the road.
Danger really is everywhere.
Off in disguise.
Absolutely shatters any illusion
of safety.
Adrian and Dag immediately
react, whip the horses, yell
run, trying to get the wagon out
of there.
But the adventurers do they run.
Not this group.
They stand their ground.
Sarn's axe flares with divine
light, Radley brings up his
blade and arcane shield.
Dermons rapier flashes, tracks
it or unleashes radiant bolts.
It's immediate pitched combat
under that pale sky.
Fur and claw versus steel and
holy magic.
How does the fight go?
They managed to take down to of
the werewolves.
Steel and Sanctity win the day
against two of them.
Their bodies fall onto the road.
But you said there were three,
right?
The third one slips away,
transforms fully into a wolf,
just melts into the forest,
vanishes like a phantom among
the trees, gets away.
OK, so.
A partial victory, but a
reminder of constant danger and
another loose end, potentially.
This whole encounter just
hammers home the peril, doesn't
it?
Even a simple journey is life
threatening, and it highlights
that growing rift with their
allies forced by their own grim
choices.
What are they becoming?
That's the question that echoes
as they continue on.
So as we wrap up this deep dive,
where do things stand?
The wine barrels are still
creaking towards Kresk, a new
destination, but zero guarantees
of safety.
Henrik's skull is still in
Surin's pack, isn't it?
Dripping, Probably a heavy,
gruesome reminder of their
choices, The darkness they're
wading through, maybe even
embracing.
Absolutely.
And the bones of Satin drawl
still lost, maybe being used for
something horrible back in
Valaki or Raven Loft.
An unresolved quest.
A lingering threat among many.
Meanwhile, Lady Walker rules
Valaki firmly in Stroud's name.
Her tyranny is just the newest
layer of oppression, proving how
quickly things can get worse,
even in Barovia.
And Stroud himself, he just
waits.
Patient has the grave.
His dinner table is still set,
metaphorically, or maybe
literally.
His invitation, his power, it
just hangs over everything,
silent, pervasive.
In Borovia, the fog always hide
something nasty.
The sun is never quite bright
enough.
Never.
So it leaves us with this
thought, doesn't it?
What does it really mean for
people for heroes to actively
fight an evil that seems all
powerful?
Especially when you know every
step forward might just be
tightening the news, trapping
you further in its web.
And maybe more importantly, how
much of yourself, your own
humanity, are you willing to
carve away piece by piece, just
to survive in a land that
demands so much sacrifice but
offers so little hope?
Yeah, it makes you consider
those impossible choices,
doesn't it?
And when your whole world is
twisted by something truly
malevolent, can you even win
without losing a fundamental
part of who you are in the
fight?
It's a heavy question to leave
you with.